in Thailand there are over 40,000  buddhist temples but there's only one  that looks quite like this completed in  2004 what I am is a collection of  temples and statues located on Koh Samui  Thailand second-largest island these are  active temples and a tranquil place  where quiet reflection is encouraged and  appropriate attire is a must  one of the most eye-catching figures is  the statue of the Buddha which is 30  meters high and painted in bright red  white and gold  the main statue at Wat pile a.m. is the  Buddhist goddess of compassion and mercy  Duan Yi here she's represented with 18  arms which shows her ability to help  many people in need at one the temple is  surrounded by a lake filled with hungry  fish visitors who make a donation to the  temple are given a bag of fish fruit  people also buy fish and turtles at the  local food market and release them into  the lake Buddhists consider it an act of  spiritual merit and the fish and turtles  do too  [Applause]  you